ANANTH SUNDARRAJAN: Hello,
and welcome to Next OnAir,
and welcome to our
session on managing
enterprise-scale distributed
business and operations
on Google Cloud.
Before we jump into our
exciting talk today,
let me take a moment
to introduce ourselves.
I'm Ananth Sundarrajan.
I manage the Go-To-Market
function for Telco, Media,
Entertainment, and Gaming in
the Google Cloud Professional
Services.
I am joined by Venk Subramanian,
Director of Engineering
at Unity, who has been
instrumental in Unity's
migration into GCP.
I also have Som Roy, who heads
our professional services
scheme in the San
Francisco region.
In this session,
we will walk you
through how Unity and
Google are partnering
on making this world
a better gaming place.
We will walk through
Unity's migration journey
and how Unity has been
managing, scaling, and unlocking
the part of their
GCP environment,
especially during our
current pandemic situation.
We will also walk through a
behind-the-scenes story of how
Google Cloud account teams and
professional services teams
have been and continue
to support Unity
throughout this entire journey.
Before we dive into the details,
for those of you who have not
heard about the Google
and Unity partnership,
here's a quick
overview from Venk.
VENK SUBRAMANIAN: Hello.
I'm Venk, and I'm a director
of engineering here at Unity.
We are the world's
leading platform
for creating, operating,
interactive real-time 3D
content.
Here at Unity, we believe
the world is a better
place with more creators in it.
This is our philosophy,
and it is at the heart
of everything we do.
We want to empower developers
with our real-time 3D
technology to help turn
their dreams into reality.
Unity focuses on
giving content creators
a single end-to-end solution for
everything they need to create.
And we do that with
best-in-class tools
and workflows that
empower content creators
to do more and operate,
enabling creators
to launch their
content and support it
with a full stack of
engine-agnostic services
that make things
easier for developers,
keep their content running,
help them optimize it,
and even monetize
and drive revenue
through in-app purchases
or serving ads.
To give you an
idea of our scale,
3 billion apps were
downloaded last year
that were made with Unity.
Half of all games are
powered by Unity, averaged
across console, PC, and mobile.
And those games and content
from many other industries run
across 20 platforms,
including game
consoles, mobile phones, AR/VR
devices that Unity supports.
We give developers the
power to target and optimize
their content to reach the
widest possible audience.
I also want to highlight that
our cloud services usually
operate at over 100,000
requests per second.
So building a strong GCP
management foundation
was critical to our success.
ANANTH SUNDARRAJAN: To
support Unity's global scheme
and developer needs, Google
has partnered with Unity
for years on a broad
and significant level
across the company.
A number of official
strategic partnerships
help our critical elements
of the Unity platform
and solve hard problems
for the developers.
For example, Google Cloud's
partnership with Unity
puts connected games at the
fingertips of all developers.
Regardless of
engine choice, they
have access to tools to
build live multiplayer
games more easily and without
needing to be a cloud expert.
We also provide the back-end
cloud for nearly all
of Unity's cloud-based
products to [INAUDIBLE]..
Stadia and ARCore partnerships
offer integrated platform
support to Unity
game developers that
want to publish
to those platforms
with familiar tools
and workflows that
make it easy for them to build
once and deploy anywhere.
AdMob's partnership opens up
Unity's extensive mobile ad
network to Google
brand advertisers
and streamlines how publishers
with Unity mobile games
can monetize their apps.
And finally, DeepMind leverages
Unity for a search platform
to run large-scale simulations
in virtual environments
[INAUDIBLE] AI and machine
learning and so on.
If you go a layer deeper into
all of these partnerships,
a key factor driving success is
how well Google and Unity teams
collaborate on everything
from product development
and capacity planning
to technical support,
co-marketing campaigns
for product launches,
and much more.
This mindset is especially true
of Google Cloud's partnership
with Unity.
In relatively short
time, we joined
to kickstart the Connected
Games initiative that I just
mentioned, and as
part of it, co-founded
Open Match, an open
source project created
to help game developers
solve the tricky problem
of matchmaking,
which is matching
the right players together in
a live multiplayer environment.
We were thrilled to release
the production-ready Open Match
1.0 earlier this summer.
GCP infrastructure also helps
Unity's Multiplay, a game
server hosting platform,
scale into the cloud
when needed to support new game
launches and unexpected player
demand spikes.
This was the case last year
when Respawn launched the battle
royale game "Apex Legends."
50 million gamers went online
to play in the first 24 days,
including 1 million
in the first 24 hours.
Flexibility was crucial.
GCP helped Multiplay
scale quickly
into its servers in seconds,
not hours, with zero downtime.
Unity Simulation and
Unity Game Simulation,
two exciting new cloud-based
products in open beta,
also run on Google
Cloud, allowing
Unity to accelerate
product development
and upgrade both
servers at scale.
All this amazing work at
Google Cloud and Unity
have achieved so far started
with migrating Unity's
infrastructure onto GCP.
Unity's philosophy of
democratizing game development
is synonymous with their vast
and distributed engineering
footprint.
With key development hubs
spread across three continents,
this posed a unique challenge
for the migrating teams
who work cross-border
towards a single goal.
To support this geographically
distributed migration,
the professional
services team was
quick to bring together
amazing individuals
across the globe who ensured not
just technical presence in each
of Unity's development hubs to
provide technical assistance
and guidance, but also to
be close to Unity's team
and partner with the
teams during the migration
and also celebrate together once
the migration was completed.
We completed the
entire migration
over the course of nine months.
The key here is the
first three months
we spent on discovering,
strategizing,
and planning the migration.
By the end of the
third month, we
had a clear understanding
of how and when
we wanted to migrate the
workloads to minimize
any disruption.
But the journey does not
end with the completion
of migration.
Rather, it only created a
launch pad for all of the future
workloads Unity was
able to bring on to GCP.
We launched "Apex
Legends" game, which
I spoke about earlier,
in Q1 of 2019,
right after the migration.
And since then,
we've been working
on onboarding Unity's
acquisitions such as Vivox,
deltaDNA, ChilliConnect,
and Furioos onto GCP.
This increased footprint also
required careful planning
in terms of capacity
in key markets,
both on Google's side
and the Unity side,
to ensure scaling when needed.
We saw the results of
this careful planning
when the number of gamers surged
during the past six months.
Let's get into some of
the details of how Unity
has been managing this large
GCP landscape with a very
agile team.
I will let Venk walk us
through the secret sauce.
VENK SUBRAMANIAN:
Last year at Next,
we talked about how
to effectively manage
a migration to GCP.
This year, we'd
like to follow up
with what happens once
you're running in GCP.
This next section will
help you understand
how to efficiently manage a
business at scale in the cloud.
The first thing to
plan for is continuing
the momentum and
engagement you've
gathered moving over to GCP.
Don't wait to finish up.
Plan ahead.
Here are some examples
of ways we did that.
We re-architected key portions
of our stack to leverage GCP
managed technologies.
New products, like
Unity Simulations,
were built foundationally
to leverage GCP.
We also worked
closely with Google
to build our partnership
through joint initiatives.
After setting the
initial direction,
we had a simple vision
going forward with managing
our high-scale
technology in GCP--
manage your operating expenses
like you manage your revenue.
This vision was realized
in three strategic areas--
GCP organization,
budget management,
and capacity planning.
Let's dig into the first
strategic area of focus,
GCP organization.
I have found that Conway's
law provides valuable insight
into setting up effective
technology organizations.
In our context,
Conway's law states
that a system will mimic the
organization structure that
built it.
We applied this principle
to enable engineering teams
by setting up GCP to mirror
the organizational structure
within Unity.
For us, that meant a flat
project and folder hierarchy,
where folders lined up with
organizations and projects
lined up with product services.
We also automated all
these capabilities
so engineering
teams were empowered
to own their infrastructure,
while at the same time
following common standards,
including business-level
tagging to make it easy to track
spend and map it to products.
We restricted and
automated production access
using Slack bots and
provided standard modules
that engineering teams could
use to build VMs, databases,
and more.
Finally, we applied
Conway's law in reverse
to set up our core
infrastructure teams
to mirror the GCP management
systems we put in place.
This also included
establishing a DevOps culture
within each organization
so they were empowered
to own their infrastructure
and organize in the way that
suited their business.
Today, we have
established successfully
a DevOps group in every
organization across Unity.
Let's move on to our
second strategic area
of focus, budget management.
GCP provides a deep
set of tools to manage
enterprise-scale
budgets, further enhanced
by partnership with TAMs.
Let's break this area
down into a few sections.
The first section is spend.
The most important thing for
you to know and understand
is your spend--
not just the numbers
itself, but how
it relates to products,
services, and technology.
GCP provides helpful tools here
for you to regularly review
the breakdown of where your
GCP spend goes using reports.
Once you understand
your spend, you
can build custom reports
for leadership visibility,
and also to enable your teams to
own and manage their GCP spend.
Data Studio is a
great tool here.
The next section is to
focus on forecasting.
This creates the
ability for you to have
predictable future GCP spend.
Here are some simple guidelines.
Tag all your infrastructure with
business-related information.
Formulate a unit.
This means creating a
formula that maps your GCP
spend to your business outcomes.
In our case, an obvious
one was the GCP cost
to serve up a single
request and establish
that cost as the baseline
we wanted to optimize.
Once you have a unit,
create automation
so you can regularly attribute
GCP spend to these units.
It also helps to understand your
discounts and credits in order
to do this.
Establish a process of
doing regular forecasting.
And do that by integrating it
into your business planning
processes.
It also helps to have a
cross-expertise working group
to manage and optimize
this forecast.
Finally, plan and commit.
GCP provides helpful
tools to commit,
including GKE committed
usage discounts, BigQuery
fixed slots, and more.
For you to be able
to commit, you
need to have an effective
planning methodology.
Look to align with
your business strategy.
The last strategic area of
focus to cover in managing GCP
is capacity planning.
This lets you plan ahead
for any cloud technologies
you will need to scale
into and collaborate
with Google ahead of time.
Here are some key points.
Work with Google to
understand your region, zone,
and [? SKU ?] limits.
Use forecasts to plan for
capacity ahead of time.
Communicate these forecasts
and capacity needs
with Google ahead of time.
And iterate.
Consistency and
predictability is
built by doing this regularly.
This year, the
pandemic has become
a critical and disruptive
facet of our lives.
As the world
quarantined, at Unity,
we saw an increased
engagement with games
from players across the globe.
Here are some ways
we planned for it.
From the get-go, we focused
on staying ahead of the scale.
The last thing we
wanted to do was
disrupt the player experience
due to our inability to handle
traffic during these times.
This meant focusing on our
users and their interactions
with our systems and staying
ahead of potential issues.
Our central infrastructure teams
doubled down on their focus
on GCP--
in particular, SRE
and the engineering
teams with ownership
of high-scale services.
This also led to proactive
collaboration with GCP to plan
for upcoming scale needs.
Finally-- and I consider
this to be so important--
as our engineering teams focused
on handling increased scale,
we also doubled down on our
focus on their well-being.
It's easy in such cases to feel
like it's all hands on deck.
But it is equally important
that your engineers focus
on their personal
health and well-being
and that they feel supported by
their organization in doing so.
I encourage you to be
intentional in planning
for this.
These philosophies on managing
enterprise scale in GCP
have worked well
for us at Unity.
And I look forward
to hearing from you
on how it has helped you too.
SOM ROY: Thank you, Venk,
for really giving us
a good view into
how Unity's managing
their operations on GCP.
So in this last bit today
in the presentation,
we are going to talk about
how, on the Google side,
we are enabling Unity's
success behind the scenes.
And the first part of that,
what we want to talk about
is the shared goal is that the
Google team and Unity had laid
out at the beginning of
our engagement together
and how we have continued
it through the years.
You know, the Google PSO
team and the broader Customer
Experience Org., including
our CSM team and support team,
and Unity had taken a
#SharedGoals approach
to this relationship, which has
ultimately resulted in shared
success and has also
helped Unity in its bigger
mission of empowering
creators across industries
and around the world.
Setting up this shared goal
was really, really important
because that led to the creation
of our joint success framework
that I want to talk about,
because this was really, really
important, again, to
enable and making sure
Unity is successful on GCP.
The first pillar of the
joint success framework
is the deep engineering
partnership.
Unity engineering and
Google engineering
are tied to the hip and not--
engineering interactions on
a daily basis is the norm.
And that's how we have managed
for the last two years, which
ultimately leads to Unity
shaping a lot of the Google
products that--
and include really
strongly influencing
our product roadmap.
Unity engineering and
Google engineering,
again, partner on open
source contribution as well.
Open Match is one of the
well-known open source
contributions that
we have had jointly.
There's many more that
we are working on.
And then finally, Ananth talked
about the "Apex Legend" launch.
A launch like that
would not be successful
if we do not do proactive
capacity planning
for each workload
that we're onboarding
and each launches
that are happening.
And proactive capacity planning,
understanding the requirement,
making sure those
regions and the zones--
like, we are planning
to the capacity,
has really, really
been helpful for Unity
to scale up on the platform.
So that's all on the deep
engineering partnership
that we have across these
different attributes.
Next part of the pillar is the
professional services and Unity
interlock.
The PSO team has been working as
an extension of the Unity team
for the past two years.
What that means is some of the
team members globally working
on Unity account has actually
spent more time at Unity
than they have at Google.
That's how close we
are to the Unity team.
And that's how PSO is working
with them for the last two
years.
Secondly, a lot of our
internal developer tools
has already integrated with the
developer workflow for Unity,
which means that we
have been able to foster
a lot of collaboration
between the two teams
and the TAMs have
been primarily really,
really important to
enable that collaboration.
A third piece is what
the TAMs are enabling
is many, many multiple product
management sessions for each
of the existing products and
what's coming down the pipe.
I know you saw in the
deep engineering partition
where I talked about how Unity's
shaping our product roadmap.
That's been enabled through
these product sessions, which
the TAMs are driving and
doing each and every quarter.
And finally, the other thing
that the TAMs really help
is the war room setup for each
of these critical launches.
Like, when a new game
launches-- and again,
talking to the "Apex
Legend" launch,
they had 50 million users in 24
days that Ananth talked about.
Like, to manage that scale,
we need to have war room.
Things always might go wrong.
So setting up this war room
for every critical launch
is really, really important.
The third pillar of
the success framework
is enablement and learning.
That means GCP training
is well integrated
into the curriculum of Unity's
internal learning path.
That means each and every
engineer who touches GCP has
to get upscaled on GCP.
And I'll talk about what we are
doing from our side to enable
further training within Unity.
Right now, we have
about 100 engineers
from Unity already
taking multiple classes.
And we're aiming to almost
double that number this year.
And then finally, Unity
and Google are always
partnering on evangelism event.
Like, for example, this
is one of these sessions.
But then also, we
have participated
at Unity's event, which is
Unite, and jointly presented.
So overall, we are always
kind of sharing our story
with the broader world through
separate evangelism events.
And then finally, the last
pillar of the joint success
framework is the
strong exec sponsorship
that we have from both sides.
We have executive-level
leadership councils
that meet annually
or biannually to talk
through how things are
going and reviewing
the broader partnership.
We have quarterly
technical reviews
each quarter to assess
the partnership goals
and also plan to work
out the priorities
for the next coming quarter.
And then more tactically, there
is weekly program management
sync for strategic
alignment and making sure
what we are doing
on a weekly basis
is aligned to what Unity
needs at the moment.
So all of this put together
creates the joint success
framework that has--
[INAUDIBLE] talks about
the engagement model
we have with Unity that we have
taken over the last few years
as Unity has scaled, migrated,
and scaled up on the platform.
Next, I'm going to
talk about particularly
how Customer Experience Org.
within Google has been helping
Unity begin behind the scenes,
enabling all of the
things that you saw.
I talked a little bit on TAMs.
The TAMs are working on the
long-term success and advocacy
and bringing the product
expertise and best practices
to Unity team.
We have three TAMs
aligned globally right now
who are supporting
Unity day in and day out
as they scale up
on the platform.
Second point, and I'm
going to double-click
on this in the
next section, which
is foundation and training,
which is [INAUDIBLE],,
again, enabling Unity on GCP
just from a scale perspective.
Third is a very
important piece, which
is the Google Customer
Reliability Engineering
Program.
We call it Google CRE Program.
And the CREs are
basically ex-Google SREs
who are customer-adjacent.
And our CREs have been
partnering very closely
with Unity's SRE team to design
for reliability, operational
readiness around
particular applications
that we are
onboarding, as well as
making sure we are configuring
platform signals so we are
proactively getting alerts when
potentially something might
go wrong in the future.
This has been a very,
very critical element
of making sure Unity
has a great customer
experience on the
the platform, just
being proactive
about these things.
And then lastly, again, I
touched upon this a little bit,
which is the go-live and
the critical event support.
Every time we are
setting up war room,
making sure we are planning
the capacity, making sure
there is dedicated
support engineers
looking at the metrics as Unity
goes live either with a game
or with a particular workload.
Finally, the global
support operating model.
Our support team operates 24/7.
Each and every Unity P1 case
is responded within 15 minutes,
making sure that there
is somebody looking at it
every time something
critical happens.
Our support team is getting
more and more context-aware.
That means that they know the
architecture Unity is using.
They know the different
scenarios and the different use
cases Unity has so
that they can come
to a resolution much quicker.
This is done through creating
shared operational playbooks
and customer context.
And the TAMs are
playing a key role
on making sure our support
team is completely aware
and has context on
what Unity is doing.
So all of these elements of
customer experience coming
together, again, is key to
making Unity successful on GCP.
The last piece that I'm
going to focus on now is--
again, I talked about this
in the last two sections
already, which is training
and training at scale.
Unity is a pretty
large organization.
They have hundreds of engineers.
And making sure
those engineers are--
they know GCP and skilled on
GCP is really, really important.
So Google PSO is collaborating
constantly with Unity
and partners to deliver
at scale on the learning
objectives of-- we have already
trained a hundred engineers.
Our aim is to almost
double the number.
We are identifying
the training needs.
We are creating
customized courses
to make sure they are fit
for use and fit for purpose
for Unity's engineering org.
We are doing
multiple coordination
and scheduling across the
group because, again, they
are very decentralized in
terms of the engineering
presence across the world.
We are enabling sessions.
And then we are also,
with sponsorship
from our leadership,
have been enabling
the team to even get
certified on the platform.
So we definitely trained
over a hundred engineers now.
But we're also looking to double
the numbers in coming months.
So all in all, I talked
about the different elements
behind the scene
that Google is doing
to make sure that
Unity is getting
successful on the platform.
Obviously, it has
taken a village
to make the customer successful.
These are all the team members
who have worked day in,
day out across the globe
in different regions,
trying to make sure that Unity
scales up on GCP successfully
and can help its partner to
launch games on the platform
successfully and
also overall have
a good operational experience.
So again, all of them couldn't
be present in this session,
but I just wanted to call
out that it takes a village
to support a large enterprise
account like Unity.
So thank you for
everybody here who
has successfully--
from Google side,
who was helped support Unity's
journey over the past two
years.
So, massive, massive kudos.
So that brings us to the end
of the presentation today.
Thank you for listening
to me, Ananth, and Venk
as we went through
the Unity stories
and how they have scaled up
and are managing operations
on the platform.
Thank you so much for joining
us today, and all the best.
Thank you.